en este vídeo vamos a hacer algunos
ejemplos para encontrar el dominio de
algunas funciones imagina que tenemos
efe de x igual a x + 5 ok esto entre x
menos 2 ok
cuál será el dominio de esta función
para el vídeo e intenta encontrarlo bien
hagámoslo juntos el dominio es el
conjunto de todos los valores de x que
al evaluar esta función obtenemos un
valor de salida definido valores que
hacen que fx esté definida entonces cuál
es la situación en donde ftx en este
caso no está definida
bueno si podemos encontrar un valor de x
tal que hagamos este denominador igual a
cero entonces aquí tendríamos un valor
indefinido entonces podemos decir que el
dominio
en este caso son todos los valores
reales tales que
bueno que esta parte de aquí que x menos
2 no sea igual a 0
entonces que x menos 2 esto no sea igual
ahora bien típicamente las personas no
querrían ver simplemente tales que x2 no
sea igual a cero entonces podemos
simplificarlo un poco aislando a x del
lado izquierdo si sumamos dos de ambos
lados entonces me va a quedar lo
siguiente observa del lado izquierdo me
va a quedar que x no tiene que ser igual
a 0 más 2 a 2 positivos y también
podrías haberlo hecho en tu cabeza si
quieres mantener x menos 2 es distinto
de cero entonces x no tiene que ser
igual a 2 ok entonces por lo general las
personas dicen que el dominio de esta
función son todos los valores reales
tales que x sea distinto de 2 bien
hagamos otro ejemplo esta vez digamos
que de x
es la función raíz cuadrada de x 7 cuál
es el dominio de esta función
cuál es el dominio deje de x pausa el
vídeo e intenta averiguar lo bueno
podemos decir que el dominio déjame
ponerlo así
todos los valores reales de x
tales que
y pondremos alguna restricción a esto
bueno habrá que pensar cuando esta
función raíz cuadrada principal deja de
tener sentido hay que recordar que si
buscamos la raíz cuadrada principal de
un número negativo entonces la raíz
cuadrada no tiene sentido por lo tanto x
7 lo que sea que tengamos adentro del
radical por aquí debe de ser mayor o
igual a 0 por lo tanto pondré tales que
x menos 7 sea mayor o igual a 0 ahora
otra forma de decirlo es si sumamos 7 de
ambos lados tenemos que x es mayor que 7
así que tenemos escribiendo de esta
manera tal que x sea mayor o igual
todo lo que hice fue decir ok para que
valores este radical deja de tener
sentido bueno si tomamos valores de x
donde esto me dé un número negativo
estaríamos en problemas por lo tanto x
menos 7 lo que sea que tengamos dentro
del radical debe de ser mayor o igual a
0 y si decimos que x menos 7 tiene que
ser mayor o igual a 0
si sumamos 7 de ambos lados vamos a
llegar a que x debe de ser mayor o igual
a 7 bien hagamos un último ejemplo
definamos htx como la función
5 esto elevado al cuadrado cual es el
dominio de esta función
bueno pues escribamos dominion son todos
los valores reales de x y ahora será que
necesitamos restringir la un poco bueno
hay algo que pueda causar que no se
pueda evaluar para un valor definido
observa podemos elevar al cuadrado
cualquier valor si me das un número real
y lo elevamos al cuadrado obtendremos
otro número real por lo tanto x 5 puede
ser lo que sea y por lo tanto x puede
tomar cualquier valor entonces en este
caso el dominio es todos los valores
reales de x no tenemos ninguna
restricción como en los otros dos
ejemplos en los otros dos cuando tenemos
algo en el denominador que pueda ser
igual a 0 entonces tienes que asegurarte
que eso no suceda porque eso nos daría
valores indefinidos de manera similar
para un radical no puedes tomar la raíz
cuadrada de un número negativo y por lo
tanto una vez más tenemos que tomar eso
como una restricción